concentrate to get rich but diversify to
stay rich i think you can get relatively
rich through diversification i don't
think you need to concentrate for most
people they're probably fine have a
great life live a decent life with that
type of lifestyle and it's much easier
than trying to concentrate and then you
get hit with some crazy risk and then
you lose more money or something you
know it's really tough that way
the world of personal finance i find
quite interesting cause it's similar to
diet in that everybody needs to eat
similarly everybody needs to have money
and earn money and yet it seems like
there is no
widely accepted wisdom about the single
best way to construct your financial
life i understand people have different
requirements but it does kind of
surprise me a little bit that it's still
so contested even though everybody
should have an opinion on it
yeah definitely i think it's contested
for a host of reasons because i really
don't think there's like one right way
to do it and i kind of you know i've
discussed this a little bit like there's
that i think that
line from anna karenina which is like
you know all happy families are the same
but all unhappy families are unhappy in
their own way well it's kind of the
reverse in wealth management which is or
start with like building wealth like
there's like only a few ways you can go
broke but there's a lot of different
ways you can get rich right those people
got rich in real estate there's people
who got rich buying stocks individual
stocks you know index funds you know you
can name it farmland whatever there's a
lot of ways people get rich but everyone
goes broke one of like a couple ways
it's usually high risk high spending or
leverage or some mix of those things
there that usually causes it so that's
kind of how i look at the world so i
think that's why it's contested because
there's real estate people saying you
have to own real estate you have to do
this and there's stock markets say no
real estate's dumb i don't want to waste
time doing that the hassle of a frozen
the pipe that bursts at night there's
always that same tail right and i think
they're both wrong i think there's both
there's pluses and minuses and everyone
has their biases and i can get into mine
but i think that's why it's contested
yeah you're probably right
what do you think
are the biggest myths
in personal finance i've only a couple
of times uh dropped into finn twitter
which i didn't even know was a thing um
but i've been cc'd in a couple of times
and it's a it's a complete cesspool um
so
yeah talk to me about the biggest myths
that exist in personal finance
so i'll just i'll talk about three of
the biggest and personal finance the
first one i think is that you can um
cutting spending is like a reliable way
to build wealth now unless you have
really high income and you have really
high spending that's the only way it's
going to work for most people cutting
spending just isn't like a reliable way
and the reason i say that is because you
actually look at the data and i was
using you know data in the united states
on you know how households spend money
there's not much to cut for a lot of
lower income households and the fact is
the savings rate is positively
correlated with income so as people's
incomes go up their spending does go up
but not as quickly as their income so
that difference is how you save money
it's pretty obvious so the best way to
actually save money in a psychological
way is actually to earn money because
you're going to end up out earning your
ability to spend
yes generally i mean of course there's
everyone's like well i know this person
who spends all their money well like yes
that's the exception most people with
higher income don't do that and i think
and obviously some people are going to
hear them say well that's very obvious
to me i'm like yes that's the obvious
point but there's a lot of people i mean
there's still a lot of personal finance
gurus that say you need to cut your way
you need to get rid of your law tasi and
you stop doing this and that and i think
anyone who's looked at the data will see
obviously like it's clear that incomes
go up with savings rate like savings
rate is positively correlated with
income the higher your income is
generally the higher savings rate that's
like been empirically proven across a
lot of studies and in a lot of ways so
that's the first one i'll talk about the
second one i think is more of an
investing question which is like there's
this idea of like oh i'm waiting to buy
the dip i'm just gonna save cash until i
buy the dip right and i think this um
this one's a little bit more difficult
to understand but i think it's a subpar
strategy because generally most you know
equity markets over time have gone up
and to the right over the long term so
by sitting in cash you're usually going
to lose out because you're waiting for
that dip and by the time that dip occurs
you're now buying at a higher average
price and so like imagine the the price
is 100 you're like okay i'm going to
wait till there's a 20 dip that i'm
going to buy now the price goes to 200
right and now let's say there's a 20 dip
so 20 of 240 so 200 minus 40 is 160 so
it goes from 100 to 200 goes down to 160
now you buy you're like wow i bought
this dip i'm so smart but it's like you
just bought 60 higher than what you
could have bought you know before now
it's it's usually not that drastic but
imagine that on a much smaller scale
right and so that's that's why you know
waiting to buy the dip doesn't usually
work and and behaviorally it's really
tough because while the market's dipping
that's the time when you're gonna be
least enthusiastic to buy you're like oh
my gosh you know march 2020 if you were
like oh wait this is a deal and then
like you bought and then it's like oh
wait it went lower and lower and lower
and then you're like oh my gosh i didn't
get a deal after all so you're gonna
beat yourself up um so that's another
thing and the third piece of that is
like
even if you you win now
what you're gonna think you're a genius
and then later you're gonna hold cash
and the dips not going to come because
those dip big dips are rare and then
you're going to miss out so i think
that's the general course of history and
so that's another myth which i would
like to smash
um
and let's just do it though i usually
talk about 401k but i know like if i
knew a probably more global audience so
let's not discuss 401ks and like stuff
in the us um the third big myth i think
is out there is that everyone says like
debt is bad there's a lot of people that
think debt is bad i think debt is can be
good or bad depends on how you use it
and depends on kind of your you know
your what's going on your financial
situation so the thing i like to say is
debt is best for people who don't need
it if you don't need debt you can use
debt really well for example i'll use a
very extreme example a lot of the super
rich like elon musk and people like that
they use debt all the time it's like how
because they take their assets they give
them up as like collateral and then they
borrow against it because rates are so
low so they end up not having to sell
anything sell down their equity have to
pay taxes there's a lot of benefits to
that when the when the after tax yield
on selling your you know your capital
gains and everything is higher than what
you would get from just paying the
interest rate so i think there's a lot
of ways people can use debt um in a
smart way and i just think you have to
if you don't really need it then it's
really useful to you it's kind of one of
these ironic things you know like rich
people get paid a higher interest rate
because they have more money in the bank
than poor people right it's like it's
very weird how that is but that's just
like a general rule of life and that's
the same thing with with debt as well
yeah three three myths would you say
that people that are highly leveraged if
they've got a property portfolio or
whatever 25 percent loan to value
um is that the same thing would you
consider that being like a smart use of
debt so to speak because i'm leveraged
up to my eyeballs when it comes to the
property portfolio that i've got in the
uk
but all of those are positive uh cash
generating machines they're all sitting
at a good interest only mortgage etc etc
is that another way to look at it
yeah i think i think it's higher to look
at is like how much yeah it's debt to
leverage ratios matter that that matters
a lot and i think
in terms of leverage whether it depends
how you're using your leverage and
everything but i think like the leverage
thing i like to look at it's like warren
buffett never went over like 1.5 to one
and that's like he was a stock investor
obviously he wasn't buying property but
if warren buffett never took more than
you know 50 above his capital and
leverage then like you definitely
shouldn't right so like just it's about
how much you do it's how much and how
much you want to you know crank that up
right i think that's the key and so
obviously there are probably certain
cases where if there was some sort of
crazy
you know
local event that like happen to hit all
your properties in a way you never have
insurance like there are cases where you
can still get wiped out but they're
probably very very very rare and very
unlikely they have to be like almost
world ending and in those cases like
your investment portfolio doesn't matter
so it's a bigger problem
yeah there's bigger problems if that if
the stock market does go to zero if the
s p pulls back by eighty percent you've
got concerns about people fighting in
the streets and like mad max going on
outside so yeah i understand all right
so let's let's let's begin
what i like about the new book that
you've just released is that you break
up personal finance into sort of its two
components like the saving slash earning
and then the investing right so income
and the output i guess on the other side
so how do people know
which one they're supposed to focus on
first
yeah so in the first chapter of the book
i talk about something called the save
invest continuum and everyone's on this
continuum everyone on the planet you
have to figure out you just need two
numbers and you can figure this out
first number is how much could you save
in the next year assuming it's a
positive number right if it's negative
that's weird that we have all sorts of
other issues there but let's assume you
could save like i don't know thousand
bucks ten thousand bucks whatever ten
thousand pounds in the next year that's
your first number your second number is
how much can your investments earn you
in the next year right so the example i
always give is let's say you had twenty
thousand pounds or something and you're
getting five percent on that you know so
that's a thousand pounds a year so you
have ten thousand pounds you could save
you know in a year give a thousand
pounds you can earn right so that's ten
to one
whatever one's bigger that's where you
need to focus and so what what do i mean
so in this case if you could save ten
thousand pounds a year but your your
income can only er your investments can
only earn you a thousand you need to
find ways to keep get that money and get
it invested so you raise the other
number you want to raise the investment
number as much as you can until it's
like almost equal to what you can save
right ideally and over time you should
see this happen with the growth in the
market like when i first started this i
had almost no investment income right
but i could save a lot more money and
over time i basically started saving and
now i'm at the point where i i basically
can save as much as my portfolio can
earn me in a good year assuming there's
a good year obviously if there's a down
year doesn't you know it's not going to
matter but if there's a really bad down
year i couldn't save my way out of it
like it would take maybe two years of
income of savings to get my way out of
like a bad year or so like assuming i
sold i'm not going to sell but that's
assuming i sold right and i'd like make
up with that cash it might take me a few
years so that's that's a simple example
you just see like where am i focusing
and over time what you should see happen
is you should move from the savings you
can save more to over time your
investments should be able to earn more
than you can save right and a simple
example does this right imagine you're
23 years old you have a thousand pounds
in your um whatever in your brokerage
account or whatever
even a 10 return that's 100 pounds
that's nothing you go spend that out at
the pub or whatever very easily right
but now imagine
you know you have 10 million pounds you
know even a 10 drop in your portfolio is
a million pounds it's like a lot of
money right you're not going to be able
to say unless you have a really really
high income you're not going to save a
million pounds in here right so those
are extreme examples but they show like
in certain cases investing is everything
and in other cases it's all about what
you can save and so usually that's
correlated with age two so that's the
thing to think about there
what does that look like practically
when you're saying you need to focus on
saving or you need to focus on investing
like how does that manifest in people's
lives
yeah so for i'll the example i'll give
when i was 23 i was spending way too
much time on my investment so what i
mean by that i had spreadsheets about oh
here's my allocation here's i'm gonna
optimize this i know it should be five
percent bonds or ten percent bonds i'm
caring about all that what i should have
been doing was building my skills you
know networking more with my career
doing all that to focus on the income
aspects of my financial life not the
investments because i didn't have that
much money to invest right and so what
does that mean on the opposite side
let's say you're 65 years old you're
retired you can't really save anymore
all you have to care about is like what
am i doing my investments i need to care
about taxes i need to care about tax
yield there's all sorts of things that
when you're 22 it doesn't matter you're
like oh should i do like a roth ira or a
normal ira or should i put it into 20
bonds or 10 bonds when you're 22 it
doesn't matter it really doesn't outside
of like a couple lucky people who bought
an nft that went up 10 trillion percent
it that's very rare that should not
happen again those things are incredibly
rare like outside of those exceptions
like it's not going to matter like your
ass allocation is not going to matter
that much it's going to matter a lot
more when you have a lot more you know
money at stake basically so that's
that's what i think about i say where to
focus i mean like how much time and
energy what are you focusing on are you
caring about taxes are you caring about
risk are you caring about things that's
the investment side or are you caring
about your career and how you're going
to build income that's the saving kind
of earnings side what do you think
nfts
and crypto
and
these huge balloons in individual
personal wealth that's been facilitated
pretty much exclusively in the last 10
years i'm sure that you could probably
give me an example from history when
some stocks gone wild as well but you
know like ballistic
neat
wall street bets sat at home people that
are being made what do you think that's
teaching
us about what it means to either be rich
or be financially successful or be
wealthy because i have sue some concerns
about what i think this means sort of on
a broader psychological
basis for
so
people
think if you'd asked me this question in
november 2021 it would have been a far
more it would have been a far better
question because back then all the tech
stops and all the tech stocks in the us
were up a lot
crypto was up a ton right right now at
bitcoin as of this recording is trading
at 40k which is like not half but like a
you know a little more than half below
where it was right its peak so you start
thinking about all these things and like
if you had asked me that back then the
lesson was oh everyone gets rich but
it's a bull market now that these things
are down 40 50 percent there's a lot of
people who got rich in 2021 that are now
seeing those losses and in big ways now
of course those people that got into
crypto and nfts and you know early you
know 2018 2019 when all these things
started popping they're doing very well
regardless um i hope it doesn't teach
the wrong lesson of like oh i'm i'm
smart when i did this and so many people
i'm not saying you're not smart i'm just
saying you might have gotten lucky and
if you if you recognize there's some
luck in this process that's what's
important i'm not saying you're not
smart like you saw something i didn't
that's true but does that mean you're
going to see every other thing that
someone else isn't going to see that's
the question
some people saw something that you
didn't others just [ __ ] memed their
way to multi-millionaire status like
don't get me wrong there are there are
people out there i have a friend uh who
told me about ethereum in
2016 when it was 23. and i put about a
thousand pounds maybe 2 000 pounds in
and it went from 23 to 110 and then it
had a little pullback and i was like
right cool i'm out [ __ ] yes bro 4x my
investment
and i you know that that to me still now
is like what and and it was in uh etoro
as well so it was um it would have been
tax-free because it's just whatever bet
bet spreading or whatever it's called
um
but
the concern that i have especially
around sort of the nft craze and and
crypto and stuff like that
it seems to me
that there is a big chunk of people this
isn't everybody a big chunk of people
who do not give a single [ __ ] about the
fundamentals about the technology about
what it can do for people in war-torn
countries like the ukraine who can't
send money back to their families people
that are under dictatorial rule that
have got whatever financial
uh bureaucracy that's stopping them from
doing stuff that's what they say it's uh
how would you say um ruthless
capitalists masquerading as good
samaritans and you go dude if it wasn't
for the fact that you can make millions
and millions of dollars off this
would you still care
no you wouldn't no you wouldn't and [ __ ]
off if you say that you would you would
not give a single [ __ ] you like the fact
that it's you can sit in a hoodie and
meme your way to millions of books
that's what you like about this don't
tell me that it's again there is
technology that underlies nfts that may
be useful in the future there is
technology that underlies the blockchain
that almost certainly probably will be
useful in the future but don't start
[ __ ] telling me about why like
cardano neat is this beautiful thing and
it's going to change the whatever it's
like no bro you're long on you're long
in this [ __ ] investment like you have
the
the highest number of uh perverse
incentives here [ __ ] off yeah the skin
skins in the game right yeah even like
i'm a big proponent of stocks and low
cost stock index funds but even like my
you know of my equity portfolio which is
even you know it's only like i think
equities are only 70 of what i own right
in total you know the rest is bonds and
and you know i do own some crypto and
some art and some other things right so
that's the rest but some reits as well
but so of the 70 only half of that's in
u.s stocks right because it's kind of
close like i basically try to get a
market weight cap so like my total
investment portfolio is like maybe 35
u.s stock so even if i'm like yeah you
guys should buy like u.s stocks or
whatever like that's only benefiting me
35 percent of right you know where
someone's 100 cardona i agree with what
you say and yeah there's there's
obviously those types of perverse actors
some people do it for the fun they're
just it's their momentum they're really
momentum traders that's what they're
doing they're following momentum and
that's fine that's that's a strategy
that's worked but it's really tough
because when it turns against you it
turns against you really badly so you
know i know the data on that and i don't
recommend that people go out and just
try and do that type of stuff i think
it's very difficult to do especially
over the long long run but you're right
i think it could be teaching the wrong
lesson to people but you know what i say
is you know as long as people have like
tried to help and try to tell people and
try to get the message out there like
you know at the end of the day it's like
you know there's a great book devil take
the hindmost you know just let it let
chips fall or they may you know we can
we can try so much but at some point you
have to be like hey like you made the
choice you know if someone's lying to
somebody that's one thing but if you're
really trying to like get the message
out there help people and these people
are still like oh you're stupid i know
what i'm doing then you know what can i
say to you so yeah i wonder that
especially yours and we're both friends
with morgan housel as well and i think
your your investment strategy and his uh
aligned sort of pretty pretty perfectly
um
he
most of the people that i respect when
it comes to growing personal wealth
don't talk about sudden out of the blue
wind falls that you discovered in the
ass end of a reddit thread like that's
not where wealth is created
um and yet because the
uh how would you say like the cream
rises to the top in these sort of big
stories that are kind of sexy and cool
and a bit sort of heterodox and
contrarian and [ __ ] the man it's gme bro
like
yeah i i i don't get me wrong dude i
[ __ ] loved that [ __ ] last year i
loved that but
the subtext that it teaches people is
it's not about having a consistent
reliable replicable investing strategy
that you can do for the next
x decades of your life
it's about
timing the meme right it's about finding
the right dog coin that's next going to
do whatever the [ __ ]
yeah and my question to those people is
like okay
someone some of you are gonna have
talent are gonna do this and you can do
it but can you do consistently i don't
know i'm just gonna say let's just say
we don't know but like
what's like is that the best use of your
talent or should you just like find a
low cost you know index fund or real
estate or whatever you buy income
producing assets when i talk about the
continual purchase of a diverse set of
income producing assets that is my
investment philosophy and you know in
one phrase and
just spend your time doing something
that's more valuable for you chris that
might be hosting a podcast for someone
else it might be something else right so
it's like if you instead of doing this
right now and like getting out there and
having you know people that you know
listen to your stuff and learn from you
if you said you know what i'm going to
spend all my time gme stuff it's just
silly it's like you would obviously be
better suited doing this and there's a
lot of people out there that are wasting
time
you know following pursuits that aren't
really what's best for them like what
really fits their talents and that's
that's the real tragedy here in my
opinion because obviously some people
should be doing it but and there's
probably too many people chasing this
alpha that shouldn't be
so okay so getting back to the way that
people look at saving
uh you mentioned there about the
difference between
spending less or earning more and
there's a good debate around this there
was always something icky not icky
that's the wrong word
there was something i didn't like about
the
fire movement the financial independence
retire early and i i think it was a
combination of this kind of like
overbearing frugality with a complete
obsession in young age about finances
and the fact that you kind of need to
put your nose to the grindstone to get
that going um so stripping all of that
back and all of the ideology that's
around this sort of stuff what do the
stats say when it comes to
spending less versus earning more
yeah so we talked about this a little
earlier but basically like when you earn
more like that's very highly correlated
with savings rate so like the more you
earn your spending doesn't generally go
up with your with your higher income and
you can look at this across like income
deaths i'm sorry um income
quintiles you know groups of five right
twenty every the you know the bottom
twenty percent the twenty to fortieth et
cetera right and you look and you see
you say okay here the income um
quintiles here how much are each one of
these groups spending you look at each
one of those quintiles and you see the
spending does increase as it goes up
right as you would expect right people
generally who earn more generally buy
nicer stuff but it's not that much nicer
i call it like the law of the stomach
like it's not like if you earn 10 times
more than me you're going to eat 10
times more calories right like you're
just gonna eat you know you might even
eat less calories probably now right so
it's like it's one of those things where
like you know at some point your
consumption is not going to keep going
up now there are people you're like but
i know someone's like yes there are
exceptions to the rule but they're
exceptions right and i think i love this
i love when people say you know what
like cutting spending's everything
controlling your spending everything
because like look at these rich
celebrities that went bankrupt like look
at this rich celebrity that rich
celebrity or this you know and they'll
have they'll have you know a good number
of examples they may have ten examples
right i have a celebrities that went
bankrupt i'm like okay you have 10 i
have every other celebrity like you're
you have n equals 10 i have n equals
number of celebrities minus 10 right
it's like it's like are you thinking
about what you're saying
you know it's like you're like you're
literally like every i could name every
other celebrity that's rich right too
and that's like a lot of stuff in the
space it's like i don't really care as
much about mindset i know mindset
matters for raising income i know what
matters for you know getting yourself
motivated i would not debate that but
like
mindset's hard to test and until we can
get some sort of brain monitoring so we
can understand mindset i think the data
shows its income like for example i know
nothing about the rock or oprah right or
any other you know pick up or you know
paul mccartney i know nothing about how
they think about money and their money
mindset right someone may know something
but i don't know but what i do know is
they all have high income right they all
have you know wealth of some sort that
provides them with income and i know
that with with a fact so i know that
they can probably save decently because
they have high income i don't know if
they're good with money they could be
terrible with money but they're still
not as terrible enough to offset their
massive amounts of income right that's
the key you know so i think thinking
about that is what's important so just
you know that's why i try to challenge
these types of things well the reason
that the rock's rich isn't because he's
optimized his avis points on his like
flyback
miles and stuff i've just never you may
be doing that oh you well you've
probably got a guy that does that but
yeah
there's a i don't know what it's called
do you know what it is what's that group
of people that do youtube videos about
how to get all different special types
of cash back and like hack cash back
with different cards and like rewards
cards stuff yeah
credit card hacking or something i think
i've heard of that i know what you're
talking about i can't remember the name
like points guys like that's like the
website for this there's a huge huge
community of these people on youtube and
i kind of watched a bit of it i was like
i'm so not compelled by this it just
seems to me
it's such a more sort of forward-focused
growth-oriented strategy to go after
earning
more whether that be through not
necessarily always working harder but
looking at leverage like leveraging your
skills leveraging your network so on and
so forth so yeah i think we're in
simpatico there uh talk to me about
being able to spend money guilt-free
because this is something that i uh
struggle with chronically
yeah so i think there's two things to
focus on when you're trying to spend
money the first is like think about what
fulfills you and find you and you have
to the hard part this is kind of a
philosophical debate of the sorts of
like people have been asking this for
you know thousands of years you know
know thyself right that type of like
philosophical like the better you know
yourself the the easier it is going to
be for you to spend money and what do i
mean by that it's like i for example
don't spend a lot of money on clothing
necessarily like this is this t-shirt's
like eight dollars from amazon or
something you know i don't spend a ton i
don't have a car i'm 32 never had a car
i always live in big cities uber and you
know subway everywhere
but i do spend a lot of restaurants i
live in new york city i like going to
nice restaurants i will spend what some
may consider an exorbitant amount of
money in restaurants that's fine because
that's what fulfills me and that's what
i like just like someone else may like a
fancy watch or a fancy car etc i think
the most important thing is to figure
out what you like and don't always
listen to studies studies help a lot
they can help guide but you need to test
and learn basically i think let me give
you an example of this for example
you've probably heard or your audience
probably heard like
hey you know
experiences fulfill people more than
material goods like a fancy car or watch
it's better to go on a vacation and have
a nice watch right but that's the
average result right you have to realize
like if most people let's save like you
know 60 or 80 of people are extroverts i
don't know the exact number if that's
true then if you ask most people they're
going to be like people that like to go
out and do stuff they are going to
prefer to spend their money on doing
stuff like going out being extroverted
but if you're if you're in the minority
where you're not one of those people who
enjoys that and you're just listening to
what everyone else is telling you you're
going to make you're going to go on
these vacations be like i didn't really
like that that much i actually would
prefer to stay home and like have a nice
watch and maybe go to like a local
restaurant or something i don't know i'm
just coming up with theories here but
you get my point like don't just listen
to what everyone else says and i mean
data matters don't get me wrong i'm the
biggest proponent of data but it's a
guide it's not like a foolproof thing
you need to really understand yourself
so it turns out to send money to kill
free fulfillments the first one the
second thing i use like tricks and so
one of the tricks i use called the 2x
rule it's very simple let's say you
wanted to buy a pair of shoes that cost
like i don't know 300 pounds very
expensive nice stretches you want to
have them for a long time but you're
like oh that's kind of a splurge for me
so if i'm going to spend 300 pounds i'm
going to save an another 300 pounds so
2x so 600 pounds in total i'm gonna you
know invest that in the stock market or
i'm going to invest that in a property i
mean maybe you can it's hard to do 300
pounds into a property but you get my
point i'm going to put that into a
savings fund that i eventually invest
into a property right the first thing is
fulfillment the second thing you want to
think about is what i call the 2x rule
and the 2x rule is very simple right
let's say you want to buy a let's say a
nice pair of dress shoes you know let's
say they're going to cost 300 pounds you
want to have them for a decade you're
going to have them for a long time um
but that's like a sport free that's a
that's a bit that's a bit more money
than you spend on dress shoes so what
you do is you save an additional 300
pounds so 2x 600 pounds in total and you
take the other 300 pounds that you're
not spending on the dress shoes and you
invest in stocks or you save it to
eventually invest in real estate or you
even donate there's a lot of things you
can do to kind of get your mind out of
this so that's what i would say to think
about is like find tricks you can use to
like mentally get rid of the guilt
you're like oh i'm guilty i'm spending
this 300 pounds on this shoes like oh
well i'm also investing in my future so
that's great or i'm also helping a
charity i care about so anything like
that would be
really useful where do you think the
guilt comes from when we spend money why
do you think it's there psychologically
yeah so i don't know as much about the
uk but i know in the u.s there's a lot
of like messages out there like you
should be spending less you should be
cutting your lattes you should be like
and that message is being repeated so
many times that people get into a space
where anytime they spend money they
start getting in their heads a lot i
think that's a lot of it another thing's
personality some people just have a
personality trait where
it's really hard for them to spend money
and that's that's much harder to get
over i don't know the way to do that if
you're like someone who just you know
you just can't spend money no matter how
rich you are i'm not gonna be able to
help you with that you're gonna have to
like look more into that um but i think
that's where it comes from i think
there's just a lot of guilt out there
there's a lot of guilt that we put on
each other that's not necessary i've got
a bunch of friends we're all working
class right north east of the uk working
class of the working class and slowly
over time we've managed to clamber our
way bit by bit probably up into middle
or upper middle class or something like
that
but man your spending habits actually
this isn't true some people's spending
habits
outpace
their uh movement through the class
system
other people's lag behind and me and a
ton of my friends are whatever dynamic
it is that we have
lag behind
so badly
so so badly we've i remember
this one time
a little while ago now i'm much better
than this but as mid 20s right 26 27
i've been running this nightclub
business for ages and it's really
successful one of the biggest in the
northeast of the uk then we start
opening up other cities whatever i
remember i was in asda one of our
supermarkets i was looking at the um
different types of yogurts that were
available and there was asda's like
finest range which is the top of the
range one and then there was as there's
normal range and i remember spending at
least two minutes vacillating between
whether or not i could treat myself to
get the
pack of four yogurts that was whatever
one pound sixties five more or something
and that was it was a real formative
experience that i had on my own in after
looking at some yogurts because i i
realized like at that moment
dude this it simply does not [ __ ]
matter and then over time as you start
to actually learn a little bit more
especially naval's book uh eric's book
about naval really helped me with this
that look um with those sort of
decisions just expedite them optimize
for satisficing just get the decision
done and be happy with the decision and
for me a lot of the time the happiest
sort of decision that i can make is one
that i do quickly i actually take a lot
of satisfaction from just uh yeah fine
cool that one if i allow myself to sink
into the decision for a lot longer that
paradox of choice comes up i start
finding myself being more of a maximizer
than a satisficer um but yeah man i
there's something about
being having that working-class
background and and sort of coming
through and you just never
i don't know if money was
not a
a problem growing up but just you you
were always conscious of of being frugal
right and sort of not splurging
and there's something i don't know
whether it's hard-coded into your dna
you can definitely get better over time
but it's very conscious for me to to
spend money that being said
same as you if i'm out at dinner i have
absolutely no problem just going to town
with crispy brussels sprouts side that's
15 bucks for no reason at all because i
just want to taste them you know
it is strange the way that we spend our
money in the way that we have that i
think the the psychological impact of
that is um
it's pretty unique you had a story that
i enjoyed about the vanderbilts
and their lifestyle creep can you tell
people that story
yeah so the vanderbilt it's actually
very funny so cornelius vanderbilt who
was the original i don't know patriarch
of the family right he grew his he grew
the fortune to like i think it was 100
million dollars or something in like the
late 1880s i can't remember the exact
figures
and he gave it all to one of his sons
just one of his sons he had two sorry
was that the richest was he the richest
person on the planet at that time
he was up there he was up there i don't
know if he was the richest he might have
been the richest i can't remember the
exactly that he's like top five for sure
he's top five you know of his era
and he's like i'm not gonna split my
money because i know that's gonna split
the fortune so i'm gonna leave it all
with my the sun i trust the most so he
gave basically mostly all of it to one
sun that son managed it well and it
doubled basically he just managed the
railroad well like everything went well
right um
and he was in railroads mostly yeah and
so but then the that's where the problem
started in the next generation that that
that family grew up knowing only you
know think about it like cornelius grew
up with nothing basically his son grew
up with kind of nothing and then they
got rich but his son son right he's
chronicles his grandson grew up in only
opulence right so that next generation
is where everything just went when
haywire and they just started spending
like they so i i don't know if you knew
this but in new york city on i think
fifth avenue you just have all these
mansions now it's all just massive
commercial buildings imagine mansions
people just walking up until literally
the most expensive real estate just
living there they had all these mansions
all they threw these parties like that
there are stories about parties where
they were on horseback like everyone was
on a horse in someone's house like
dining eating like like networking i
don't know how you would do that you
know you ever been in a place where you
have to hold like a you know a food and
eat the food and drink at the same time
imagine that on horseback i can't even
imagine they were doing that they'd
smoke like cigars rolled with hundred
dollar bills remember this is in the
1880s or something it was like absurd
1890s or even early 1900s whatever it
was and there's just this insane amounts
of lifestyle creep which is just unheard
of and it's i don't even say it's
lifestyle creep it was just the sense of
like well they had a very high income
and like the the fall you know
cornelius's son so the second generation
never really spent that much but then
the third generation's like no our
spending should match our income right
and then they just
match and then they basically lost
they lost almost everything in the great
depression they had to sell so many
things like they sold uh one house at
like you know one percent of the value
they bought it at like just fire sale
stuff like it was that bad no one could
afford any of these luxury goods so they
got wrecked but that's kind of a great
story about like what can happen when
you're when you're spending's out of
control so dude that
that [ __ ] blows my mind and it is it is
one of those things where you presume
that dynasty wealth is just going to
continue you know you hear these stories
about whatever it is like uh if jeff
bezos drops 100 bucks on the ground it's
quicker for him to earn it again than by
his passive interest than it is for him
to bend down and pick it up in half a
second or something so you do kind of
think that wealth is this unbeatable
thing and i wonder whether
there must come a point there simply
must come a point where the critical
mass
of your wealth
can outstrip essentially any desire to
spend it shy of trying to pick up nation
states you know if you've got 50 billion
or something like that i actually don't
know whether it would be possible for
you to but the point is going back to
that this lifestyle creep right the fact
that your tastes can outstrip your
ability to pay for them um over time and
that's kind of the story that i was
talking about with the with the working
class thing and it does really seem to
be sort of two types of people i can't
remember who it was this was a morgan
household quote where he said um
lebron james is rich
the guy that writes his checks is
wealthy
and he's talking about the difference
between oh lebron james seems to be a
relatively smart businessman too the
that sort of athlete mindset you know
like some kid that maybe grows up in the
hood or whatever and then
has never had cash but
super keeping up with the joneses very
much bothered about their
labels and status and stuff like that um
one of the things that i thought was
interesting to do with lifestyle creep
your one of your solutions to it
is to kind of
mediate increases in wealth versus
increases in spending which you can
explain in a second
take me through that but then also
explain
how someone that's self-employed
where those changes in income and wage
aren't quite sort of as obvious to see
you you just sort of get big chunks of
cash maybe you're on dividends you're
drawing down maybe you're on a higher
commission structure it's a little bit
more difficult to do so how do people
uh protect themselves from lifestyle
creep and then what do you do if you're
self-employed yeah so to protect
yourself against lifestyle creep i mean
i've actually run simulations on this
like you imagine someone just getting
raises over time and it's like you
straight linear raises over time of
course that's not exactly how the
world's gonna work but if you assume
that and you say okay i'm on like a good
decent let's say you're on a decent
financial path now you're like on track
to hit your retirement goals whatever
you're in a steady state we'll call an
equilibrium the question is how much of
my raises can i spend to stay on that
track and i find that on and i show in
the book there's a table it depends how
much you're actually saving now so if
you're a really high saver now you have
to actually save even more of your raise
than when you originally save and it's
very counterintuitive but we can go into
that in a second
um basically i say like roughly it
converges to about 50 so ironically the
number in the book is basically 50
because that's where most people saving
they have lower savings rates and so if
you save half of your raises or big
bonuses you can spend the other half and
you it's not going to affect your
financial future which means you're
gonna be able to keep your consumption
consistent over your lifetime right if
you don't do that if you spend more than
that then you're at some point your
consumption has to drop off or you have
to do something else or have some other
income that comes later
out of nowhere that offsets that so
that's one thing to think about i think
what you're talking about like you know
lebron james is rich and the person who
writes his checks is or is wealthy right
i think it's just like stock first flow
type thing like like lebron james or
someone has high income they have a high
flow but that doesn't mean they have a
high stock right they have they don't
have a bunch of wealth that's just
paying them consistently right so and i
think the you know the premise of the
book and i even was talking about
earlier the same invest continuum that's
the difference between you know the flow
which is your income and the stock which
is your investments right and how that's
going to lead to your flow right so
that's kind of the thing there but i
think the biggest way to kind of stop
lifestyle creep is just to like make
sure you don't i mean i i give some
recommendations in the book i think the
50 is about right and actually matches
the 2x rule ironically so it's like very
simple to remember it's like half for
you and half for future you so if you're
saving at least half of those raises for
future you can keep doing that pretty
consistently um
and obviously they're edge cases where
that's not true but i think if you're
doing that that's you'll you'll be
decently well off right so you don't
have to be saving 50 of your total
income but if you're saving 20 now and
then you get a raise save half of that
raise
there's a
stat or a story that i heard around the
government was struggling to get people
in the uk to increase their pension
contributions but they knew that they
needed to
uh and what they found was that there's
a psychological it's loss of version
basically right that or
coupled with anchoring bias a little bit
that like this is what i was at before
and now you're trying to what take more
away from me uh but what they found was
that if they suggested to people that
when they get a raise that a
increased portion of the raise was
contributed to their pension people were
just well up for taking that off so i
think that it works
in terms of the stats it works
financially but it also works
psychologically as well so the pain of
doing that of holding back on like money
that you didn't have
is going to be significantly easier for
everyone yeah that's why i say i think
you have to be in a decent financial
spot initially because if you feel like
you're struggling to get by or you're
like you feel like you don't live the
life you want and then you get a raise
you're going to want to like spend all
of that to get to where you want to be
right i'm not going to lie like you're
going to feel that way right but if
you're like oh my life's decent i like
this this is good and then you get one
of these what i call positive shocks or
a raise or a bonus then saving half you
can do that right so i just as long as
you're mentally in a spot where you feel
okay with what your current spending is
and how you're saving and everything
that's when the race and stuff will work
if you're in a spot where you're not
it's gonna be really tough to only save
50 if you just feel like you're just
living a subpar life compared to what
you want to live
so what about renting versus buying
that's a very difficult question i think
it's probably one of the most difficult
questions out there and my my law my
long story short conclusion is i think
you know at least within the us
most people are going to buy the
question is not if but when i think the
main there's two things to think about
one societal reasons it's like you can't
rent in certain neighborhoods you want
your kids to go certain schools you
can't rent renters aren't allowed there
is a lot of stigma around renting versus
buying
that's one piece of it the other thing
which is a big benefit of owning a home
is like you do lock up your housing
costs right like you you're not paying
the market rent every single year like i
i've been a renter my whole life so i've
been paying the market rent every single
year and going out i do basically once a
year on average and i go and pay the
market rate right and so because of that
you know rents have gone up and so i'm
paying more over there now someone say
okay well if you locked in a mortgage
and let's say 2012 i didn't have money
but let's just say i did have money to
do that you know i could have locked in
something great but i would have to pay
for you know the taxes on that the
maintenance i couldn't move i couldn't
be mobile there's a lot of things with
the today's world where everything's
remote it's a little bit easier to do
that but back in the day i didn't know
if i was going to live and i started in
san francisco then i was in boston now
i'm in new york so i jumped around a lot
so
in the book i kind of discuss all the
specifics of how much do you have to
have ready to buy or versus rent and all
these type of things but those are the
main issues i think about and even the
people i know that are like very
anti-renters i think a lot of those
people end up buying anyways and if you
see like homeownership rates generally
go up with income as well so for the
most part people end up buying um does
that mean you have to buy no but i think
a lot of people even those who are like
very anti-buying eventually buy too
because they know it's like
it's your leveraging too like you think
about it you're and right now with high
inflation with very high inflation i
think the print today was 8.5
in the united states
if your payment is fixed but inflation's
high assuming you're capturing some of
that inflation through asset prices
through your job you're getting raises
that are matching inflation at least
then you're going to be paying back that
that payment is fixed but your income's
going up so it's like imagine you know i
think the example given the books my
grandparents um their payment was 270 a
month when they bought a home for like
27 000 back like 1972 in california a
long time ago i know it's crazy money
seven eight bags of the pool
no not seven acres it's not a
major house but they bought this house
and they're paying 270 a month but 10
years later by 1982 that payment had
been cut in half in real terms if you
just just adjust for inflation the same
person would you be paying half imagine
your rent going down by half in the next
10 years that's what could happen
obviously that was a very high inflation
period but from now for the next 10
years we could be experiencing that
right now and then 10 years from now
that payment's lower because you locked
in when everyone else didn't so that's
something to think about one of the
things that i
like about home ownership at least with
the way that i am in the uk again a
disadvantage of being from the northeast
of england uh bad weather
not fantastic international flights and
this working class mindset around
spending money where you focus
obsessively on yogurts but one of the
advantages is that the value that you
can get from a property
is insane man like i i've got i'm just
going through on my six house house
purchase now right some of those are
five beds the most recent ones are four
bed with an ensuite in every single room
none of them have ever been more
expensive than half the average house
price
of the uk if you go on rightmove.cod at
uk right i think the average house price
is about 345 and the most i've spent on
any property is uh 170. right um
i've got my house that i live in uh with
two
of my housemates that are like my
buddies that live there as well um so
that i understand one of the challenges
people have if i buy a house then that
restricts my freedom especially if
you're young as people are now marrying
later starting families later perhaps
wanting to be this nomadic entrepreneur
thing
cool um
again it depends on how much headroom
you've got above what you're spending so
on and so forth but i highly highly
recommend for people if they are keen on
putting money into real estate if they
like that security
spending your money by getting a house
with at least two other lettable rooms
means that you basically zero out a lot
of the risk pretty much all of the risk
right so the property that i have back
in newcastle yes i'm not benefiting from
the fact that i'm living there which
would have been significantly cheaper
but i'm also not losing money by having
that property continue to take over
because i've got two guys that live
there who pay me their rents for each of
their rooms now
i'm in an airbnb in austin at the moment
paying 3000 pounds a month because it's
a long stay airbnb so that i mean that
stings you know i'm paying the mortgage
on the house at home plus i'm paying
whatever three grand to be here but
it still makes sense for me financially
it still takes over it keeps everything
moving so yeah
to try and sort of fly the flag for
someone who really likes uh real estate
as an investment strategy um but also
wanted that freedom and that liberty to
be able to move around
thinking about getting a property which
you can then
i don't know whether you call it sublet
in america or use
whatever yeah lodges or tenants or
whatever that's in there and by doing it
this way i've got a room in a house in
the uk where if all hell breaks loose if
i've got a catastrophe with the family
if i need to get home for a wedding or
whatever it is that's always mine that's
always there and there's a cleaner that
goes every two weeks for 40 pounds and
she makes sure that the entire you know
it's not degrading over time that it's
being kept in good
it's perfect and that that to me is a
real lovely blend of of the two
obviously again you need some capital to
put up in order to be able to make that
work you need to be in the right place
if you're living in london or slightly
more expensive cities you're going to
struggle because you're just not going
to be able to get on the ladder quite as
easily
but that's one of the solutions that
i've found
yeah everything that's an issue with
this it's always relative to your
situation so it's really hard for me to
give blanket statements when like yeah
if you're living in you know
northeastern uk it's very different than
living in london very different living
in new york city very different living
in like you know tennessee or something
you know rural tennessee or something in
the united states so there's all these
different factors you have to take into
account but i agree
let's say that someone hasn't been
interested in investing at all they've
just been spending their money like a
normal human what do you say to somebody
when they say that they can't be
bothered to work out investing why is it
for me i don't really get it it seems
like a lot of work i don't want to do it
um think about your future self i think
you have to be selfish i think you have
to because if you actually look at the
data on they ask you about savings
motivations why they say save and invest
money
and the one that works they can be like
oh what do you want to say for a
vacation it doesn't work safe for your
children doesn't work surprisingly the
one that does is save for your future
self like imagine they've done these
experiments where they take your face
and they like age you with this like
photo ai aging stuff so you see you see
what you look like as an old person and
i remember this one around at one point
remember there's like things
yeah it was definitely the chinese
trying to do facial
yeah but imagine that you see yourself
as old person you can now imagine wow
i'm going to be an old person doing all
this stuff so maybe i should be saving
for my future maybe i need to have
income and so in the us you know if you
don't have a pension or anything like
that you're not going to have any income
besides social security so unless you're
willing to live on that type of
lifestyle
then you're probably need to save some
money so that's the thing it's like
really what type of lifestyle do you
want to live and if you can live a
really cheap lifestyle now and you're
like i'm going to live that forever and
i don't need to save as much then fine
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
being frugal and living a really low
cost lifestyle if that's what you want
like i don't shame people for wanting to
be super frugal i don't that's
completely fine i just don't think
that's a great solution for everyone
because i don't think that's true for
everybody right and so figuring out like
what works for you is what's most
important
i
tried uh stock investing a few years ago
um i probably should have just left that
[ __ ] ethereum in and that would have
fixed all of these problems but um
i and what i found very very quickly was
i don't think that i have the uh mindset
to be a trader certainly not one that
picks stocks and the neuroticism
that i found myself dealing with around
having
a thousand pounds in activision and a
thousand pounds in apple and you know
regularly seeing swings in an entire
portfolio of thousands of pounds per day
across a not a particularly huge
portfolio you only need you know like 10
or 20 grand and you can have a couple of
bad days and you're like
i i my net worth just went down by a
thousand pounds today that's
pretty terrifying um so yeah picking
individual stocks makes that a lot worse
however since then i've taken morgan
morgan's uh and your
suggestion and i'm just in the s p at
the moment i don't
obsessively check my etoro every day um
you're not a fan
of picking individual stocks presumably
for a more
data-driven reason than mine but my
point is that i think for a lot of
people uh the psychological impact of
kind of like being in individual stocks
is a pretty high toll to pay as well
yes i agree so there's a there's two
there's really three reasons i guess why
i'm not a big fan of individual stocks
the first one is one that maybe your
audience has heard it's what i call the
performance argument and the financial
argument basically
most stock pickers active managers what
do you want to call them don't beat
their benchmarks don't beat the market
so let's say the benchmarks s p 500 they
don't beat the market after three to
five years after fees right now
everything they do they just don't beat
the market why
because on average if you think there's
fees right so imagine let's say half the
people beat the market half don't
remember they're buying and selling from
each other there's a very theoretical
argument goes back to i think
i think william sharp came up this
argument basically theoretical half the
member they're buying and selling from
each other so half are going to win half
we're going to lose and then if you take
out fees it drops that right like if
only half can be up and half can be down
then like on every trade then like only
half can be winners having to lose but
then there's fees and transaction costs
there's like some slippage in the system
so it's going to be less than half right
so that's why only like 25 percent can
outperform their benchmarks and you
don't to calculate all that there's that
they're actually already do there's
something called the spiva reports
spiva and they basically do this for you
they look at every equity market across
the planet you can say let me see the
three year let me see the five year how
did these people perform and in some
markets some people do outperform a
little bit better than others but on
average it's like 70 to 80 percent won't
outperform for like a three to five year
period is it kind of like a gambler that
is able to beat the odds in the casino
consistently over time that the longer
that you decide to stay in the market so
to speak if you're picking individual
stocks you're part of the 25 of your one
but then you're also part of the 25 of
year 2 and then you're also part of the
25 of year 3 that didn't end up being
beaten by the market so over time
consistently you actually end up being a
like a real outlier anomaly if you
haven't lost money at some point during
that period yeah yeah that that's a way
of thinking of it i i don't like to use
gambling because it's like a negative
expected value game i would say
investing's positive expected value but
what we're talking about here is
obviously as you said the relative value
like you can still make money like you
can pick stocks and make money you're
just going to make possibly most likely
going to make less than if you just put
it into like an s p 500 or a world index
fund something like that right so that's
the first argument's very well known the
second argument the one i personally
like more is what i call the existential
argument that's basically like you don't
know if you're any good at stock picking
and like there's a lot of data to show
this like they've found that like they
can only like they can identify scale in
about 10 of stock pickers so let's say
you can identify the top 10 percent you
could identify the bottom 10 percent
that's 20 out that means there's 80 or 4
out of 5 people you could play this game
for a while and not know if you're good
and i think let's let's use the lebron
james example if myself and lebron james
went to the basketball court you would
know within minutes who has skill and
who doesn't right you could tell pretty
pretty quickly right who's who's good
and who's not but if me and lebron james
were picking stocks we wouldn't know for
years maybe maybe lebron's a great stock
picker who knows right just we just
picking stocks we have the same amount
of money we have to throw the capital
you may not know for a year two years
five years and one of us could just get
lucky one of us could just have one
thing in our portfolio that just mooned
and we would beat the other person
because of that one random pick and i
got lucky so that's the difference like
there's a lot more luck in stock picking
there is in like you know computer
programming or basketball or something
where the skill is very identifiable so
that's the second argument which i don't
like what you were talking about with
like oh i had a thousand dollars in
activision like why was i obsessing on
my portfolio
i think what it does
you start to identify with the
investment right so when you pick the s
p 500 or let's say you pick a world
index uh equity or stock index fund when
you pick a world stock index fund that's
the default choice that's like that's
like oh here you go here's your choice
you're like i didn't choose that so if
the market goes down it's not your fault
right it's out of your hands but as soon
as you say you know what
i'm gonna just deviate a little i'm
gonna pick activision i'm gonna pick
apple
now you've made a choice now it's your
fault if it goes down right it's because
you made the choice you're the idiot who
made that choice but if it goes up
you're a genius right so you see it's
all an identity i think that's probably
the most compelling argument because
you're gonna start identifying with your
investments you're gonna be obsessing
over the thousand like i remember i've
done this too i had like two percent of
my my uh wealth and like individual
stocks and yet like the 98 percent was
moving up and down like magnitude's more
like you know or is a magnitude more
than the two percent yet i'm obsessing
over that because i picked it like some
idiot you know it's silly it's a very
silly thing to think about but you
obsess over your active picks you're not
gonna obsess over your s p 500 index
fund whether it's dropping you know in
the same way i think you had a couple of
stories about even you somebody that
lives in the finn twitter financial
advice world uh and you flubbed
a few uh stock picks recently can you
tell everyone about those
yeah so i've done so i remember i behold
like this is how tough this problem is
so i have a whole chapter in my book
chapter 12 called don't buy why you
shouldn't buy individual stocks yet i
have one percent of my net worth in
individual stocks and i see i say hey if
you're doing it for fun or something
that's fine like five percent whatever
do it have fun and that's what i do
basically so i keep one percent i did it
with some friends and i bought two tech
companies i'm not going to say that i'm
not here to pump my bags they're down
massively they're down bad and so one's
down like one ipo to 19 went down to
like six it's not doing great the other
one actually was at 15 went to 32. i was
feeling pretty good and now it's down at
like seven so that one's down like worse
than all the others and so they're down
bad and i haven't i'm sitting on these
losses i might sell at some point and
you know take the you know the
lost harvest or whatever but we'll see
so i'm saying it's tough for everybody
even me the person i wrote a little
chapter on this and i still do it but
like i do it for fun and i think it's
okay to do it for fun if you want to get
out of your system i just don't think
you should do it with the bulk of your
wealth because
it's a tough game it's really really
tough don't play that game so okay
people aren't supposed to buy the dip
we've
explained that that waiting waiting to
buy the dip causes you to wait for so
long that you have missed out on
potential gains to move up you've maybe
gained a 20 intraday move but you've
lost a 60
over the last year increase you should
have gone back and done that
what should people do if they're not
buying the dip
they should just be just keep buying i
mean the book it's like buy over time
like it's that simple um and what do i
so it's actually kind of ironic because
when i say don't buy the dip i'm not
saying if if you're in a dip and you
happen to have cash buy the dip right
however you shouldn't hold cash waiting
for but they're very different right
holding cash and waiting for a dip is
bad but buying a dip is good so they're
very different because let's say by
chance you're selling a company and by
chance the money hits your account on
that day right and by chance there's a
10 intraday drop in the market that's
probably gonna be a deal of some sort
relative to other days right so i mean
of course the market can keep dropping
that's of course possible but you just
got a 10 discount right and if you have
a lot of money get invested right that's
the thing and on average that's going to
make you more wealth of course it's
riskier to do that of course it's
riskier to do that there's no debate
there and if you're worried about risk
you're probably just putting too much
money into a two risk of a portfolio so
you need to figure out okay maybe i
shouldn't be putting into 100 stocks
then maybe i should be adding bonds or
adding other things that are
diversifying my wealth so that's my
counter people like i can't put it on
it's too risky then it's your portfolio
then put in a less risky portfolio and
just put it in now and then just wait
you know so that's what i would say to
people so about buy the dip what's the
nuance around dollar cost averaging and
i think it's dollar cost averaging and
then is it like average pricing in or
something there's two different ways yes
so technically right now in the
financial community there is a there's
two definitions for dollar cost
averaging and there's no way like we
can't i think the genie is out of the
bottle we can't put it back in basically
so the original definition my
understanding benjamin graham dollar
cost average just means buying over time
you're buying so like let's say you have
a 401k here in the united states i don't
know if you guys have like a defined
contribution plan whatever you guys call
that you're putting in money every time
you get paid you're not taking your
money and waiting it's not like you got
you know let's say you got a hundred
thousand dollars from selling a company
a hundred thousand pounds you would put
that money into the market right away
that's like a lump sum investment but
you're basically buying like as soon as
you can that's called dollar cost
averaging the other definition which i
in my book call average in i'm trying to
change the terms here is like if you had
that 100 000 you say i'm not going to
put it all in today i'm going to put in
you know 10 000 a month for the next 10
months until it's in right so i'm gonna
i'm going to slowly average into the
market right the problem is that's also
called dollar cost averaging so when you
have two different names for like or the
same name for two different things it's
very confusing to people because like
like nick you said lump sum beats dollar
cost averaging but then you said like
nothing can be dollar cost averaging
well it's like no that's those are
different terms and i'm trying to fix
that it's really tough um i don't think
it's gonna get fixed to be honest with
you i try to come on podcast and tell
people like let's just pick a i don't
care which one wins let's just pick a
term and go with that i personally think
the original definition should win so
dollar cost averaging just means buying
over time just keep buying they're
almost synonyms for all practical
purposes you know i mean dollar cost
averaging technically has you know what
is it six syllables and just keep buying
us four so we can just reduce the
syllable you just reduce the syllables
by 33 why not do that you know so let's
just call it that so
when it comes to the person that's maybe
got the windfall their concern might be
that if they put all of their money in
right now oh well what if there's going
to be a big pullback at some point in
the future if i do that over time i'm
going to continue to get but the again
the point is what was that uh
what's that meme where it says uh the
hundred year moving average for the
stock market looks pretty good yes
that's ramp that's ramp capital yep it's
amazing yes yeah so over time
it everything is sweet and i guess if
you have a long enough time horizon your
100 grand that just goes in today is
better than that 100 grand spread over
the next 10 months at 10 grand a month
yeah yeah so the the issue is on average
like 80 of the time you're gonna be
better off by putting the money in right
away than like in the case where it's
crashing so like you're like well i'm
not i don't care about that okay then
don't then just pay you're gonna just
realize the market's probably gonna go
up over this time you're probably gonna
lose a little if you're okay with that
do it i don't think there's anything
wrong with averaging into the market if
you're comfortable with that that's what
makes you comfortable do it don't do
things you don't want to do but there's
so many people that don't want to take
the plunge and they just haven't looked
at the data it's like generally probably
okay so that's that's my counter to that
the other thing too behaviorally the
only time
when averaging in beats putting all the
money in right away versus the lump sum
method where you could slowly wade in
when that's better is when the market's
falling that's the only time it's true
think about it right if you put all the
money in now and it crashes that's bad
so if you had if instead you had just
averaged in you're going to be buying
into a falling market but that's when
you're least enthusiastic to buy when
the market's dropping 10 you're like oh
i don't know if i'm gonna i'm gonna wait
till the dust settles right and you do
that you wait till the dust settles it's
march 2020 you're waiting i'm gonna wait
and then next you know six months later
it's a new all-time high right and then
you're like oh crap the dust settled and
now i just missed this massive rally so
my counter to that is like don't do that
it's really tough like the hardest time
to buy is the only time it outperforms
like behaviorally so that's why i say
just buy now because if you're in the
case where the market's falling over
time you're not going to want to buy
anyway so it's like you're not going to
you're not going to even follow the time
with the time when it matters you're not
going to follow it so
you said earlier on about the look
that's involved in investing how much
luck is involved and then how can people
mitigate the impact of luck on their
investments
i think the best way to mitigate luck is
just kind of your asset allocation what
how you invest your money right so it's
like are you well diversified right do
you have emergency fund do you have all
sorts of things that help you plan and
prepare for the future of course you
can't know everything right if you're
you know if you rely on like oh well i
own like three businesses that are
restaurants and then covey comes from
those lockdowns you hit there's nothing
you can do that's like some that's like
an act of god for all practical purposes
there's at some point there's nothing
you can prepare for there's certain
things you can't prepare for
but you know you can probably do
something that's going to be decent
right so i say like diversify find ways
to you know to have your wealth so that
you're not worried about some crazy
scenario everything concentrated in
apple or activation something like that
then you can get hit really bad and it
would be really tough right that type of
stuff happens right and i think there's
this there's this quote like you know uh
concentrate to get rich but diversify to
stay rich right and i think that's true
but it depends how rich do you want to
be i think you can get relatively rich
like through diversification i don't
think you need to concentrate if you
want to be a billionaire yes that's
completely true you want to be like 100
millionaire even a 10 millionaire you
probably need some sort of concentration
at some point in your life but if you're
like yeah i'd be fine with like 2
million bucks and like that'd be a nice
life i could live my life with 2 million
2 million pounds whatever it is
you probably can do that through
diversification just buying over time
and that's the thing what i'm trying to
get at like for most people they're
probably fine have a great life live a
decent life with that type of lifestyle
and it's much easier than trying to
concentrate and then you get hit with
some crazy risk and then you lose more
money or something you know it's really
tough that way
so what do most people get wrong during
a crisis
i think the thing during a crisis i mean
obviously it's tough i i'm not going to
sit here and say like oh yeah march 2020
was a cakewalk it wasn't i watched i
lived through my first real big crash
that where i had money invest where i
saw my wealth dropping 10 one day and
then up two percent then down another
temper you know i saw this happen what i
think people get wrong is
you know i think my favorite investment
quote is um
fear has a greater grasp on human
judgment than does the impressive weight
of historical evidence you know and
that's from jeremy siegel right and so
that it's that fear grasping us it's
like the world's going to end we're
never going to get better ever and i
think humans are more resilient than
people think and don't get me wrong
there are cases where markets one market
goes down badly and something you know
russia went down 80 in like a month this
year during early 2020 or sorry early
2022 and that type of stuff happens but
if you're diversified if you don't if
you own only russian stocks then yes
you're screwed if you only own u.s
stocks you could get screwed diversify
across other you know asset classes and
you'll be fine and in the case where oh
what if all those drop once again it's
one of these apocalyptic scenarios it's
not going to matter your investment
portfolio is doing you're getting a much
bigger problem so that's my counter what
think about a crisis like yes there's
fear yes there's going to be a 10-year
period in the u.s or europe or et cetera
where these assets don't perform well
they may even lose to inflation this has
happened before i i can guarantee in my
lifetime i guarantee i would say very
high likelihood that there's a 10-year
period where u.s stocks have no return
after dividends and inflation and i
don't know when that's going to happen
we could already have started it for all
we know right we're already down from
some point we could 10 years from now
we'd be like wow yeah remember when i
said that 10 years ago it could happen
but it's not about
wondering what could happen it's looking
at history and history generally you
know it's up into the right over the
long term and just keep buying and see
what happens you know what about working
out when you should sell
tough question i think there's three
times we can sell first one is just kind
of a tactical thing that you should just
do at least in the us there's a t we
have an annual tax season i'm guessing
you guys do too
you just sell when you're rebalancing
right you're like trying to rebalance
your portfolio oh my stocks did really
well this year my bonds did badly okay i
need to sell some stocks to get to bonds
there are cases to do that i don't
recommend that i would say if you're
gonna do that because there could be tax
implications i would say try to what to
do is instead of selling if you're still
accumulating income buy more of the
underweight asset so let's say your
stocks went up a lot and your bonds
didn't throughout the years you noticed
this oh wow it's going up just buy more
bonds and less stocks just to kind of
get them back into the that's just
easier and you're not going to do
there's no tax effects that's the first
time
uh the second time is if you're like in
a concentrated position you need to kind
of get out of that you're like hey this
is way too concentrated i need to sell
at least a little bit of this let's see
what do you mean when you say
concentrated
like let's say you're at uh you're at a
company and you've gone like rsu's or
stocks you've got like private stock
from this company at ipos and now like
80 of your net worth is in this company
right so i'm not saying sell it all i
don't agree with that i think selling it
all can be very risky mentally because
if you sell it all and then it triples
or it goes up 10x and you're like oh
look like we're all the world party over
here chris is the idiot who sold all of
the you know the apple stock because
he's an apple engineer and he sold it
all don't do that right but sell enough
to kind of lock in your lifestyle and
then let the rest ride if you want after
that or figure out what what's that the
mix for you right i don't know exactly
what it is but i'm not i'm not a fan of
like sell i'm not a fan of one or
nothing decisions i think it's very
scary so don't keep it all but also
don't sell it all so find that some
could mix that's the second thing right
you're in a concerted position the last
time is you're going to sell if you need
to fund your lifestyle that's the whole
point that's all point of life you know
we're here to you know you want to fund
your lifestyle you want to go get a nice
car you want to get a nice watch you
want to go to i'm going to do this big
vacation and you need to sell stuff
that's the point i know my books called
just keep buying but at some point
you're going to have to sell and you're
going to have to sell in order to fund
your lifestyle so remember that that's
the point of money we're not here just
to accumulate a bunch of money and then
die like that's not the point of life at
all and i don't want to give that
impression right i really am about you
know people living the lives they want
to live i just think
there's there's more optimal ways to do
that over time have you got any idea how
much of people's pensions slash savings
on average most people end up dying with
uh it so in the united states i think
those in their 60s i think the average
was 300 000 in their 70s i think it was
like 340 it goes up basically every
decade only in the 90s i think it went
down a little but i also think we're
also getting the generational effects
the people who died in their 90s in
these studies were probably in the
greatest generation in the great
depression they probably didn't invest
as much as people who died in their 60s
so there's generational things there but
on average like it goes up over time and
i think one of the most shocking facts
that i discovered when i was looking to
like retirement data is like only one in
like six or one in seven retirees is
pulling down principle right so imagine
you know in a given year they're living
off their dividend capital gains our
investment returns and their social
security in the us and they're not
selling down any assets i think the most
shocking stuff i've ever learned was so
michael kitzis did this analysis we're
basically like you are more likely to
forex your wealth over 30 years
following just the four percent rule so
let's say you had a million bucks you
take out four percent the first year so
40k in spending the next year you kind
of adjust for inflation you take another
four percent you're more likely to forex
your wealth over 30 years than to go
below your starting principle so by the
end imagine start with a million you're
more likely to have four million or more
than you are to have under a million
after 30 years that's what's crazy
there's a lot of retirees that think oh
my gosh how am i gonna am i gonna live
my money and then it's like oh no you're
actually richer than you've ever been
and like you can't even keep up and your
spending goes down in retirement too so
it's like really kind of shocking these
old people are so rich and they have no
idea that it was going to happen and
then their wealth keeps growing like
you know and that's that's something
that's kind of interesting to me like
i'm looking at the data like we're
talking about this retirement crisis
don't get me wrong there is a subset of
people that are really struggling we
should find policy to help them but a
lot of retirees are not struggling in
the same way and i think it's unfair or
unrealistic to like paint them paint
this like oh there's this massive
retirement crisis everyone's gonna be
starving on the streets when it's like i
don't see that happening you know in the
data at least so what was that story
about the guy who won the lottery
that story's crazy jack whitaker that's
one of my favorite stories so
uh the guy basically what happened was
you know he's watching he went to like
or it was in west virginia yeah so
there's a story yeah so jack whitaker
they're in west virginia the the it was
like the powerball or whatever it was i
can't remember the name of the lottery
but there's tickets selling like crazy
15 tickets a second or something you
know 15 15 50 45 more you know people
just caught lottery fever it's going
crazy everyone's like oh there's all
this money so this guy named jack
whitaker buys a ticket goes home to his
wife they're watching the powerball they
have five out of the six numbers like oh
they're like seven like oh my gosh like
this is amazing we won a hundred
thousand dollars like you know it's some
good money but it's not like they didn't
win the jackpot right so they go to
sleep you know they're like happy
whatever and they say okay we'll figure
that out tomorrow they go to sleep
that's it okay
the next morning gets up he's doing his
morning coffee jack looks at the tv and
he sees oh my gosh they miss announced
one of the numbers he looks back at his
ticket he's just won the largest jackpot
he actually had the winning ticket the
largest single jackpot didn't have to
split it with anyone in history like 317
million 300 million dollars after taking
the lump sum in taxes i think he has
like 160 180 million i don't remember
the exact figures in the book and saw in
there there's all this money
and
you know you're thinking like wow like
oh nick i already know what's gonna
happen right he's gonna have all this
bad you know all the bad stuff happens
his granddaughter dies of a drug
overdose he ends up jack himself ends up
getting addicted to like trying to pay
women for sex he's like drunk all the
time like all these bad things happen
like oh nick i knew this you know it's
just another lottery runner story but
you don't here's the here's the trick
jack whitaker was already rich before he
won the lottery he was worth 17 million
dollars he owned his own construction
company right and that's when you
realize that's the thing that money can
do to people this man lived in he lived
in virginia it's not like he's living in
like new york city penthouse where 17
million could like he doesn't go as far
he was living in a place where he could
basically do whatever he wanted he could
have done all the stuff he was already
doing right but as soon as he got the
money it changed him and i think that's
a important lesson there about like what
how money can affect people and so to
like think about like one is enough for
you and like realize that like i don't
even understand why he was playing the
lottery if i'm being completely honest i
think was more of a social thing and
then he won the lottery and it consumed
him completely
what do you mean when you say people
need to know when enough is enough for
you
i mean this is a great question it's
just about figuring out like at what
point are you going to be satisfied and
like okay hey here's like the level of
like consumption i want so that once i
get here i stop because if you don't
you're going to keep
chasing that you're going to say oh i've
never reached your friends and they're
doing this or they own this or they're
they sometimes fly private actually
sometimes
you're going to keep getting there
you're going to keep following that to a
point where you'll never get out and
you're going to always want more money
so and i've seen it happen so many times
in terms of in the data i've seen like
psychologically i understand why it
happens like there's always someone
richer right
every single person besides like you
know elon musk and jeff bezos are like
can point to somebody like that person's
rich right and amen because they they
flop back and forth who's the richest
all the time right so ignore those two
but like everyone else can point to them
even more buffing like i'm not even that
rich anymore look at these people you
know so it's kind of crazy but like as
long as you can always point to other
people you're never going to feel rich
and i think the example i use in the
book is lloyd blankfein who's uh ex-ceo
of goldman sachs billionaire obviously
very rich he says i'm not he's like i'm
not rich i'm will to do or something
he's like because you know why because
all his friends he's hanging out with
david geff and jeff bezos he's now with
people that are 10 15 100 times more
wealthy than he is and he doesn't feel
ritual to them and i get that he can't
go buy a 600 million dollar super yacht
like jeff bezos can right and so i get
that feeling
and you're gonna say well that doesn't
make sense he's a billionaire but it's
like he's doing a relative comparison
right and i would say like you know and
i the the example i give in the book is
you know to be in the top 10 of wealth
in the world you need roughly a hundred
thousand dollars it's like 93 000 us so
let's say 100 000 pounds right
if i say if you have over a hundred
thousand pounds you're rich right you're
in the top ten percent in the world
you're rich right you say but nick
that's not fair you can't compare me to
someone in the developing world who's
like a farmer or something that's not
fair well guess what lloyd blankfein is
going to say the same thing about you
he's going to say you can't compare me
to these average people who work these
average jobs or whatever like you can't
compare me to them i you have to compare
me to like you know jeff bezos and all
these other people these are my friends
right
that argument it's obviously a little
ridiculous but it's kind of true you're
making the same argument we're just
cutting hairs over where's the point
like oh why can't we compare you to a
farmer you know a developing farmer
somewhere in the world why can't we do
that you know a farmer developing nation
why not you're like oh but that's not
fair why why not tell me why it's the
same reason why you why lloyd blink
mine's making the same argument it's
just worth cutting hair so i think
people will never feel rich
so you have to identify as rich earlier
in your life like i did for my age for
my age i identify as rich not because
i'm not even a millionaire not a
millionaire at all but i have to do that
and if i don't do that i'm gonna keep
chasing money my whole life to the point
where i i lose myself and i'm worried
about that and so i hope i don't do that
so i have to realize i'm a rich citizen
of the globe and like think about the
privilege i have here and what the type
of impact i can make and so i think you
have to remind yourself of that and if
you don't you can really get lost in it
so that's what i say i don't say this is
like a brag i'm not that's not what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to to get myself
to think right otherwise i may ruin my
life in some way and i don't know but
that's kind of my thinking it's a
message to yourself
yes exactly reinforcing yeah dude i i
keep having this conversation with
people especially since i've been out
here in austin and austin is a very
interesting city it's a city where it's
cool to work hard and very uncool to
work very hard it's a city where it's
cool to be rich and very uncool to tell
people that you're rich like oh it's
kind of um i think because
there's so many new people here that and
there's a lot of money everyone's very
very conscious of people that are sort
of flashing their cash a lot and
yeah
that doesn't seem to me to be a healthy
movement
culture
mindset uh promulgated message
about enough being enough right
about
you
are worth a million dollars
almost every message that you hear from
rap music to personal development to the
sort of memes that you see online to
hustle culture to garyvee
almost everybody says well if you've got
a million that means that it's easy for
you to double that to get to two million
right there's this video of
patrickbetdavids where he's talking
about uh
i always think about stuff in doubles
it's like you know it's like 16 32 64.
128 256
i'm like
okay
what
like what the the this sort of autistic
view of numbers that completely actually
removes them from their purpose and the
framing like maybe there's some people
who genuinely take a lot of pleasure
from playing the game of the numbers on
the screen probably probably are but i
think a lot more people
like you suggested are genuinely
existentially attached to their sense of
self-worth based on the amount of riches
that they have
and it really really fascinates me the
desire for people to be seen as rich
what it means to be rich and what it
means to keep up with the joneses and
stuff like that and i i really do think
on one side me vacillating about my
yogurt choices is a
a weakness but on the flip side of that
me and almost all of the friends that
i've got never thought that we would be
here in any case
we didn't expect you know it's the
position that you want to be in when you
get to be able to do things and you
don't have to worry about whether you
cover dinner this evening and oh you can
pay me back next time and you you know
not having money worries is fantastic
but that's the materialism set point
that i get to and i do
i understand why people like to watch
videos of
you know like the elk boys like steve
will do it and the guys flying private
around the world like [ __ ] cool and
steve's going and dropping all of this
cash and stuff like that you go well
yeah that is that is cool but
you can get probably
95 90 of his life enjoyment with
10
or 5 of his net worth
like the things that genuinely add a lot
of value to his life
probably aren't the private jets they're
probably not that it's mostly the time
freedom and the ability to choose what
he to do what he wants when he wants
with who he wants for as long as he
wants and no one gets to tell him
otherwise and you can do that at like
one twentieth or one percent probably of
where he is i don't know i i just think
that
i'm looking forward to a more holistic
hustle culture message coming out over
the next 10 years and i'm pretty sure
that it's going to happen
well there'll be a backlash at some
point when people are like this is too
crazy that we have to do all this stuff
you know and i think that's i i think
you hit the nail on the head there it's
like figuring out what you want it's
like i actually i have a mentor who's
like tells me like you know yeah you
want to fly private like do you realize
like you have to really really hate
first class and
and the you know the costco financially
to go pride to rent private and then
from rent private it's like you're
charring to then like i own the plane
right there's all these like i you know
i'm sharing whatever it's like the cost
go up exponentially for like obviously
very small marginal benefits now
someone's like well i would never fly
you know that's fine if you want to do a
status thing and that's maybe you're
getting money you're getting some sort
of utility off the status of flying
private that's fine but like
no one's gonna care you know i get it
but like most people don't think like
that i think it's kind of it's
interesting you know so what does that
actual and perceived relative income
graph mean because i was looking at that
and this is as you go up your relative
and perceived income uh moves around
which i thought was pretty fascinating
yeah i believe it's from mit studying
you could throw it up but somewhere
maybe it's here or something i'm just
messing with that um so there's an mit
study and basically it showed that like
you know as your income goes up right
you're where you perceive you are in the
distribution does not follow with it so
people who are really poor know they're
kind of poor as you kind of get to
middle class that's usually pretty good
and then as you get above the 50 line
people in the 90th percentile even like
oh i'm like at the 60th percentile i
know all these other you know because
they probably know a handful of really
really rich people really high income
people and they're like oh i'm not as
rich as them so i'm like at the 60
percent i was like no you're at the 90
down you just know someone at the 99th
percentile that's really what it is and
so that's what's so interesting because
like at the higher levels when you ask
most people that's why when you ask you
know most americans like what class you
most americans say middle class even
people who are clearly in like the top
10 percent which i would say is you know
upper to
upper middle at least probably upper
class i think the top 10 is probably
upper class what's up
this is what we're cutting here in terms
of earnings in america do you know i do
not know off the top of my head i could
and we could google that i have no clue
what that is um but yeah it's just one
of these things where like everything's
relative so i have no clue what that
what that number is i'm going to do it
top 10 of earnings
america
let me see what do you think it is give
me give me your uh prediction
so top 10 percent i'm gonna say maybe
it's either
let's go 150 household income so here
we've got investopedia.com
uh how much income puts you in the top
one percent five percent ten percent
uh top note point one percent three
point two million top one percent
823 000. top five percent
342 000 top 10 percent of earners 173
000.
i said 150. so that was close not far
off man it's almost like you know what
you're doing yeah um but dude i uh i
really really adore the book like you
know you and morgan i think as a two-car
garage for understanding how to do
personal finance i think you've
absolutely nailed it i love the fact
that you've done summaries at the end of
the entire book that summarizes the
chapter i love the fact that there's
loads of stats and stuff in there i'm
coming at this right from someone who
requires money but gets very very bored
when sort of learning about finances and
talking about investing uh and yet for
anybody that thinks that they've
listened to this and is like yeah i
probably should learn this stuff super
accessible real plain language some
great stories in there uh you should be
really really proud of the work that
you've done dude like i i loved it so
congratulations on on getting that out
thank you chris i appreciate you saying
that it means a lot to me especially
from someone you said who's not really
interested in money that means a lot and
i do think
morgan's book is like uh kind of like
everything i missed morgan kind of like
it's like oh yeah someone asked today on
twitter like who should i read first you
were morgan like read me and then
everything i miss morgan fills in with
you yeah he's like because behavior it's
hard to quantify a lot of stuff and he's
right like ultimately behavior is the
most important thing but if you can't
quantify it it's tough for me to write
about that stuff and that's what he does
so beautifully so i think we are kind of
looking at the same issue in different
ways and so it's it's interesting to
kind of how we do that and i i love his
book i'm a huge fan of his obviously
like we're good friends and everything
so i've heard i've heard on the on the
grapevine that he might have something
else in the works as well so whatever
that's going to be is going to be
[ __ ] spectacular my lips are sealed
that's what i'm going to say okay we can
either confirm or deny uh dude look i
really appreciate you i appreciate your
work where should people go if they want
to find out more stuff about you online
so yeah my blog is of dollarsanddata.com
so of dollars in data all one word um
you can also find me on twitter at
dollars and data you feel free to dm me
my dms are open so i try to respond to
everyone i have no idea i might get way
too many but anyone wants to dm me about
anything i'll try to respond thank you
dope i love it man thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you